there are plenty of big secrets at the
scp foundation but sometimes you just
gotta wonder what are the smaller
secrets here at scp explained we often
zoom out to give you a bird's eye view
of the bizarre and sometimes
inexplicable events concerning a huge
number of anomalies but today we're
ditching our telescope in favor of a
microscope to take a look into the daily
life of one very special blobby boy
scp-999 the tickle monster we took the
liberty of painstakingly stalking um
i mean observing
scp-999 going about his daily life
bringing joy to everyone around him and
not only were our otherwise cold dead
hearts thoroughly warmed we were also
able to compile everything we needed to
make this video you're watching right
now welcome one and all to a day in the
life of scp-999
6 30 a.m
rise and shine happy campers we discover
that the tickle monster likes to start
his day nice and early after all the
more daylight you have out there the
easier it is to put the sunshine in
people's hearts so shortly after waking
up
scp-999 uses his little blobby pseudo
pods to put on some pleasant easy
listening music in his containment
chamber delightful he then drinks a
glass of delicious soy milk and helps
himself to a balanced breakfast of
chocolate m m's and a variety of tasty
fruit-flavored gummies please note this
is not an acceptable balanced breakfast
for human beings it's important to
remember that scp-999 has very different
dietary needs to us humans believe me i
tried the scp-999 diet all i got was
severe sugar headaches and overtime on
the toilet but the less said about that
the better after eating his delicious
sugary breakfast the tickle monster
grabs a crayon and starts building his
day plan which is normally filled with a
wide array of stimulating activities
every day is a new journey into
excitement for scp-999
this is part of scp-999 schedule that we
very much recommend you emulate setting
your goals nice and early may help you
solidify your goals nice and early and
also help you feel a warm and fuzzy
sense of accomplishment when the day
ends and all your errands are complete
but by the time all this is done for
scp-999
it's already 8 am of course while
setting goals for the day ahead is an
important task
scp-999 in its surprisingly applicable
wisdom also knows the power of
inspiration that's why at around 8 am
the tickle monster indulges in his
morning entertainment before any tasks
or cross tests begin this largely
involves watching cartoons on a
television set provided to him by his
handlers at the scp foundation
scp-999's favorite shows include
spongebob squarepants blues clues and
the backyardigans the foundation is
extremely careful with the programming
that scp-999 is allowed to indulge in
making sure that all the shows are
generally wholesome and sweet with
positive moral messages that one can
carry forward into their day spongebob
is a particular favorite for that exact
reason the tickle monster sees that
plucky yellow sponge as a kind of
kindred spirit reminding him to keep a
positive can-do attitude and a sense of
childlike fun after a few episodes of
the show 999 is typically bouncing with
joy and more than feeling spongebob's
iconic catchphrase i'm ready and while
it isn't necessarily relevant we'd also
like to state that within the confines
of this metaphor dr gears is squidward
moving on 10 am now the tickle monster
is really ready to take on the day
having filled up on the two essential
seas of any prosperous day candy and
cartoons he's ready to slither out there
and make a difference his first order of
business for the workday is sitting in
on the daily site 19 senior researcher
meeting where the top brass of the site
is given a collective debrief on the
day's tasks and given an opportunity to
share any vital information of course
morning meetings can be stressful
especially when you work at the scp
foundation where your daily task might
be
scp-682 seems particularly cantankerous
today am i paying a visit to his
containment chamber and asking him about
it however scp-999 being there in the
room is kind of like having the ultimate
scented candle he exudes those chill
relaxing vibes and even the pleasant
smell that puts you in a place of
profound ease the foundation has
discovered that since scp-999 has
started sitting in on the morning
meetings both employee satisfaction and
task completion have increased happy
workers as it turns out are also hard
workers when the meetings end and the
senior researchers are filing out of the
room each one of them gives
scp-999 a little hug or a pat in hopes
of thanking him for all he does this
increases their emotional well-being as
well as scp-999s
it's one of the rare everyone wins
scenarios you'll find at the scp
foundation after the meeting scp-999
tends to roam around the site for a
while searching for anyone in need as
you probably already know the tickle
monster has an innate sense for when
people are in need of his unique brand
of anomalous positivity if a researcher
or a guard is feeling down
scp-999 will have an innate sense of
their presence and mercilessly hunt them
down to give them some pep they'll never
forget allow us to give you a specific
example security officer dan richardson
was stressed while he didn't let on to
anyone else working at the foundation
fearing that showing emotion would make
people think less of him his wife was
actually struggling from a severe
illness so when he went into work even
when he was guarding the containment
chambers of truly terrifying monsters
like scp-102
he was only ever worrying about her
nobody else knew except for scp-999
when the tickle monster sensed dan's
distress he slithered over and began to
climb on him unleashing his rays of
anomalous good vibes soon enough dan
felt a kind freedom he hadn't
experienced since the beginning of his
wife's illness later that day he felt
the courage to visit the site 19
employee mental health counselor at last
and became open about his emotional
struggles it began a long but worthwhile
road to recovery all of which began with
scp-999
and then the tickle monster broke for
lunch 12 p.m at around midday every day
slithers on over to the main site 19
cafeteria to enjoy a wholesome lunch
with foundation personnel and some of
the other friendly anomalies that do
lunch with them he'll grab a bowl of ice
cream and a colorful jello pot from the
friendly lunch lady and slither on over
to the table where scp-073 kane and
scp-343 god are sitting around chatting
no hard feelings about the whole loud
mark thing right
god says biting into his hamburger it is
a process kane replies any awkwardness
that was there before immediately
evaporated when scp-999 entered the
scene both of these mysterious anomalies
smiled and began petting him as he cooed
and trilled god levitated the spoon to
feed 999 his ice cream which kane
thought was a little show-offy but held
his tongue because he was lost in the
moment kane helped 999 peel off the lid
to his jello pot with his precise
mechanical fingers dr clef who was
eating a few tables over also dropped in
to give
scp-999 a playful pat on the head and
given that dr clef typically has the
sensibility of an xbox 360 call of duty
lobby this show of vulnerability was an
exceptional act indeed dr bright would
have done the same but he was spending
lunch in o5 council detention again
because he did something really stupid
again what was it this time see if you
can guess
1 30 pm after lunch scp-999 would spend
the next half an hour having the nature
of his father the terrifying scarlet
king explained to him for those privy to
certain secret documents you'll know
that scp-999 comes from the most
unlikely of parents the interdimensional
universe-destroying monarch of chaos and
evil known as the scarlet king he was
actually the progeny of the scarlet
king's seventh bride whose son was
prophesied to one day defeat and
dethrone the scarlet king not through
violence and hatred but through love and
kindness so great it burns out the
crimson khan's darkness of course he's
not ready to go toe-to-toe with his
estranged father just yet nor would the
foundation want him to they've made
mistakes in the past by being too gung
ho and prematurely weaponizing anomalies
under their care just look at the
absolute disaster that unfolded when
they tried to make abel part of a mobile
task force and he killed all his
foundation comrades when they ran out of
missions to give him that's why they've
decided to take a very different
approach with scp-999
rather than pushing him too hard too
early they've decided to start drip
feeding him the knowledge piece by piece
every day after lunch some of the more
scholarly researchers have been reading
him choice extracts from davite
scriptures concerning the scarlet king
they always follow it up with a little
rupert the bear though just so things
don't get too intense 2pm after this
unique scp foundation take on story time
is done
scp-999 is once again free to roam
around the site dispensing joy to
whoever needs it most something you need
to understand about scp-999
is that he's utterly non-judgmental even
a beast of pure violence and hatred like
scp-682 is considered a potential friend
to 999 you may even remember the time
that 999 was able to live up to his name
and tickle the hard to destroy reptile
into submission inducing a hysterical
laughing fit in this otherwise hardcore
beasty that's why 999 would sometimes
stray into the dark spooky areas of the
site that most people would fear to
tread if they weren't specifically
assigned there for starters he nestled
up against the outside of scp-049 the
plague doctor's cell the sinister
surgeon was feeling a little down in the
dumps due to his continued failure to
stamp out the pestilence and the scp
foundation's stubborn unwillingness to
help him in the task however a loving
visit from the tickle monster even on
the other side of a plexiglas divider
was enough to chase the blues away just
when he needed the encouragement most
this strengthened the doctor's resolve
he would continue his research no matter
how many lives it took to perfect his
curative method admittedly not the best
result of an interaction with scp-999
but 999 was at least happy that the
peculiar beaked man seemed a little less
depressed now at least even if the lack
of depression may lead to a few further
murders down the line who would be next
on scp-999's rampage of joyfulness and
positive vibes
scp-999 like the benevolent is a friend
to all children so he does what he can
to improve the quality of life for
anomalous children contained by the scp
foundation as part of his daily rounds
he makes sure to always visit
scp-053 the young girl as his positivity
aura is too powerful for the girl's
anonymous ability to passively cause
paranoia and violence to affect him she
often reports having a wonderful time
during their sessions though she wishes
her big dragon friend could come join in
on their tea parties too
4pm by this time scp-999 is back to
roaming again searching out people or
anomalies he can lend a helping hand to
helping people if you hadn't somehow
realized it by now is one of 999's
greatest joy in life that's why when
slithering near the high security
humanoid containment wing and seeing
groups of researchers running for the
hills he got the sense that perhaps he
was needed here and decided to
investigate further as all the
researchers ran screaming in one
direction
scp-999 slithered audaciously in the
other he heard one of the researchers
yelling the old man got out sound the
alarm and run for your lives of course
this did nothing to deter scp-999
even as the containment breach sirens
blasted through the air around him 999
didn't fear death he only feared failure
failure in the task to make everyone
around him as happy as possible up to
and including some of the most horrific
and depraved monsters the scp foundation
has ever contained very much including
the monstrous creature coming towards
him down the hall the old man
scp-106 gave a throaty chuckle as he
shuffled down the tiles his black goo
fizzling on the ground with one hand he
traced his fingertips along the wall
spreading corruption that ate away at
the wall like a cancer with the other
hand he dragged a rapidly melting corpse
that had once been a hapless researcher
standing too close to the wall of 106's
containment chamber now the old man was
eager to cause more pain and havoc in
the rest of the facility before he was
forced back into containment until he
ran into scp-999 coming towards him in
the hallway suddenly 106 felt something
change in his mind his typically sharp
predatory sadistic thoughts suddenly
felt odd and fuzzy almost formless it
was almost like he'd been hit by some
kind of anomalous chloroform that dulled
the edge of his evil and then he was
laughing
why because this strange blobby creature
had crawled up onto his body and begun
to tickle him relentlessly it didn't
make sense how come this creature wasn't
affected by his corrosive mucus but it
was already too late he was doubled over
onto the floor cackling and unlucky for
the old man but luckily for everyone
else it was enough to pacify him until a
mobile task force with high intensity
lights showed up and shepard him back
into containment it was a truly
humiliating defeat for scp-106
but at the same time he'd be churlish to
deny that he had somewhat of a good time
7pm as we get deeper into the evening
scp-999 still has plenty to do after all
every day that ends at the scp
foundation also heralds the end of many
people's lives and that's on a good day
too needless to say there would always
be plenty of people who needed cheering
up at the end of each day and nobody was
more up to the task than the tickle
monster
first scp-999 decided to make its way
down to the site-19 medical bay to treat
everyone who'd experienced varying
degrees of horrific injury from a
typical day's work at the foundation
some were horrifically burned others
were missing parts some were pretty much
catatonic with the mental trauma of the
things they'd seen many had distinctive
fresh wounds that could only come from
scp-682's massive claws and fangs it was
a powerful wellspring of misery
scp-999 slithered from bed to bed
nuzzling up to the different patients of
the medical bay and lifting their moods
you'd be amazed at the medicinal
benefits of a positive mindset and he's
one of the few medical treatments that
won't utterly destroy you if you don't
have insurance after helping the injured
scp-999 decided to visit the d-class
barracks while most of the scp
foundation looked down on the lowly
d-classes especially given the criminal
history of many of them
scp-999 held no such prejudices he
sensed that the people in the barracks
were confused and scared for their
safety and that was enough for him to
get in there and help he slithered
through the gangway observing that some
of the bunk beds were empty from the
day's less stressful tests these harding
criminals many of which were literal
murderers immediately felt themselves
softening in the presence of this
cheerful blobby creature for the first
time in many of their long difficult and
tragic lives they dared to believe that
perhaps everything might be okay
sometime in the not so distant future
and
scp-999 couldn't be happier about that 9
30 pm as the night winds down one of the
researchers assigned to scp-999 reads
him a bedtime story to help him wind
down after an exciting day
scp-999 tries not to go to bed too late
at night knowing that an early bedtime
and an early rise ensure health and
energy whale song and white noise is
played over a small radio while scp-999
settles down to sleep ready to have only
the sweetest dreams so ends another
wonderful day and there you have it
folks a day in the life of the endlessly
adorable scp-999
is there anything from the tickle
monster's daily routine that you think
you might start incorporating into your
own day-to-day lives let us know down in
the comments personally in a world that
can sometimes be cold and cruel we think
having the strength to be a little
kinder and smile a little brighter can
make a far bigger difference to some
people than you'll ever understand and
nobody exemplifies that better than
scp-999 now go check out
scp-999 tickle monster versus the most
evil scps and children of scp-001 the
scarlet king is
scp-999 really his son for more tales of
this wholesome blobby boy